all right ted i want to start with this
is probably the most important
um first place for us to start with and
then we're going to get into what we
were talking about
in the intro is how did you at such a
young age
because we we talk about this so much on
the program is parsing
for signal and inspiring young kids
especially
to parse for signal related to not only
what are the most
uh ancient spiritual understandings of
metaphysics and the nature of reality
but also
around what are the most cutting-edge
sciences and then bringing those two
together
and and also the kids unique gift and
identifying that
you at such a young age were able to
figure out how to get how to
how to parse for that signal and became
and achieved all of your medical
successes so much earlier than most
people
do how did you figure all of that out
how did you begin
parsing for that signal at such a young
age
actually um and i have said this
before and i insist on it especially on
children
it's not to stifle their curiosity you
push
your kids and younger people to be
curious about things
and for the parents not to be
to provide pat answers to things like
god made this and god made that and
suddenly you know the child becomes
lazy what i call intellectual sloth that
plagues our society
right you allow them to discover you
allow them to get bored and they watch a
cutter
a caterpillar and then they wonder what
happens to a caterpillar
you know when you when you couple that
with the proper guidance
and you know a certain industriousness
on the part of the parents or on the
teachers
to nurture the curiosity with the proper
facts
right then you could actually instill
in in a child that there are certain
patterns
that nature follows yes and they when
and then when they realize
that when nature follows um certain
patterns
and then they could realize that
okay then there is such a thing called
mathematics that is the science of
abstract pattern
right you could see that you could
abstract for example
x plus x equals 2x then one apple plus
one apple equals two apples
right and but then when it's uh
y it's uh you know x plus y so one apple
plus one orange
equals one apple and one orange then you
could immediately see
that uh the pattern can be immediately
abstractable
and then you instill in them a love for
abstract patterns
and uh that will that will
spur them into you know more curiosity
about well what other patterns exist and
pretty soon
you know for mathematical purists out
there for example
they really love the beauty of being
able to obstruct those patterns and they
make these discoveries that way
but for us who are you know i'm i'm uh
undergrad in biology right and
and uh for me it's uh looking at
the uh what fascinates me and
what drives my curiosity always even as
a younger child is how did we evolve
you know how did we come to be this way
what were the factors in there that's
why
for example an interest in evolutionary
biology
is uh you know i i you know it should be
taught to everyone
you know um evolutionary should should
be taught every
er er er every everyone because it shows
you how we have
falled how did we get here right and
then
as you mature you should be taught the
new field now that there's a new field
called evolutionary psychology right
yeah why do we
why do we behave the way we do yeah and
uh
when you see that that's a shape by
evolution
and it's also and the evolution is
shaped the way the brain is wired the
way we're wired
right and then um and then for us to
be understanding the economic economics
where we're in
everyone should be taught you know game
theory evolutionary game theory
you know these are things are
fundamental but you could see what i'm
driving at
right yes one is the capacity to see
patterns what's the definition of genius
right
yeah is is uh
the capacity to see patterns where
others say that there are none
and the patterns exist right and the
definition of madness
is the capacity to see patterns where
others say that there are none and
they're really none
right so so
there is the thin line uh but
um and even if you take a look at iq
tests and all that kind of stuff
you know it's really your capacity to to
see patterns and to
do abstractions through those patterns
yes the clearer you see them
you know the faster the faster you are
at looking so
um i have this concept alan of what i
call
i like verbalizing nouns so
and i i love fractal mathematics right
so
um you know i look at the core pattern
you know what gets iterated over and
over what gets repeated over and over
right so for evolution it's really very
simple uh
and um you know uh it's it's a random
variation
and narrow selection right and that's
darwin's version
but now we have already abstracted that
right so we have
we have essentially random variation and
you know um
environmental selection but the unit of
selection now differs right
so for richard dawkins for example you
could see that his unit of selection is
a gene
is the gene that's being selected for
for darwin it was populations
right and um i was
hearing uh an evolutionary biologist
from harvard actually interpreting this
all wrong
you know that the the unit of selection
in darwin's case
is not the individual it's the
population that's being selected for
right it's it's kind of like
pre-industrial
england right when when there were a lot
of white moths
and then suddenly with industrialization
there were there was a lot of suit
around
right and suddenly the black moth
started to getting selected for because
they could conceal better
and the white moths started getting
eaten by the patients because they could
be seen um they could be seen right so
you could see
very easily that these are the kinds of
things that um
that selection does
but the unit of selection is different
for memes which was introduced by um
by dawkins right with not the
bastardized
internet meme that we have now but if
the unit of selection for
society and culture right when you are
going to school they
what they're doing is they're
transferring names right and memes are
behaving like genes they're like viruses
they transfer
right and these are these are like you
know um
sayings uh like like maxims like uh you
know the early bird catches the worm
right
and i like to bastardize that a lot i
say the early bird catches the early
worm
because you could see how this little
memes would affect your behavior
right so um so
you could see that it all stems from
early on
uh pushing uh pushing the curiosity
um allowing for the child to
identify you know that there's certain
core patterns there that get repeated
even if it's hidden right and then an
abstraction of that pattern to something
else that's
manipulable right yes yes so now you
could see a child growing to
manipulate you know uh a
mathematic a geometry of 64 dimensions
you know which you could never imagine
right because
introspection is usually all wrong right
you because you cannot imagine a a
geometry of
something that has a 64 dimensions but
you know
sure there there are there are
geometries now
that are occurring beyond space and time
so you know
um if you for example it occurs to them
that hey you know i can regard space and
time as an illusion and
physics is finding now the space time is
an illusion so
you could see the ramifications that are
very vast
and we need these kinds of motivations
for the younger people
not just to [ __ ] survive and
reproduce yeah i mean
because that's ordinary right yeah
that's so or
ordinary yeah that's as we do this
within two standard deviations
as as i like to say you know if that's
what we do
and then we we destroy this earth right
and
then so we go in spaceships and colonize
another livable planet
survive and reproduce erect that planet
again and go somewhere else i think
oh you know then we're not doing our job
right we're not doing a job in
determining where we want to bring our
species to
and i i presume that the reason why you
want to bring out podcasts like this is
that
you know how can we have a species
awareness
that brings us forward to where we
really want to bring ourselves
to in relation to the network of other
species that are out there in this
planet
it is our one and only host at the
moment right
and we're destroying it at a really
alarming rate
you know so um and then for and then
from and then from there
and then you you go back like uh oh you
know
the reason where those so many climate
change deniers and all that
is it's you know i i usually don't
like to say this is it
just plain ignorance right it there's
certain
as dawkins uh likes to say you know
there's a certain
form of intellectual courage right in
able
to be able to do this uh to make these
kinds of assertions
and and that intellectual courage
actually for example if you're looking
at climate change
you have to have a fundamentals of um of
uh
the second law of thermodynamics at
least but who wants to know
that let alone want to know the the
structure of
firmings and bosons and all and weapons
and quartz
we evolved right we evolved to
like to know stories because it's as
that's how we are evolved for survival
right
and for reproduction so we like to tell
stories around
you know that's why we're good at
conspiracies we're good at all of these
uh uh things that have plots and
motivations
etc but we're so poor at statistics
like for example you know the the amount
of car accidents are
a lot more than taking a plane for
example and we
we cannot realize that right because we
are made for
a nomadic group of five to seven people
we're not intended to to take a look at
populations
you know certain laws are are formulated
that way or regulations are familiar the
way the the seat belt law
you know massachusetts didn't want to do
the seat belt well because it crinkled
their clothes
right but uh from a rational they were
the last ones to enact it in law but
you know from from from from from a
rational point of view means are you
thinking statistically and this is the
effect
you know from when you get child curious
and and then um you know superimposing
science
and and mathematics you know and uh uh
and evolution how we evolved yeah and
how we came to think this way then there
is a chance for us
not to think this way to think in a
different way
right um yes and
and so we can we can think of different
solutions
right yeah for uh different solutions
for
issues and for the and that's
i was thinking about health right you
know we say we're talking about health
optimization
i know you've already gone far right
yeah
let me hit let me hit the ball back and
then we'll we'll keep
keep going this okay this this intro
segment
has been really awesome how you
explained when
the child is uh if
has the full curiosity
fully enabled and
then also there is the guiding influence
of
of intelligent parents that have
understood
that there are these patterns that
emerge and then by
in a sense abstracting out those
patterns
into pareto efficient ways of teaching
the child
about those patterns and also for the
child to they themselves
watch those patterns and for them to
fully embody the recognition of those
patterns
including the patterns of things like
why there's perennial spirituality
around the entire planet
pointing at the same nature of reality
understanding so then there's this big
synthesis that happens for the kid as
they follow their
creativity and they follow their
curiosity and their understanding the
science patterns and the spiritual
patterns and they understand
their own unique artistry role i really
like that
and also i like just the classical bell
curve
understanding where in that center is
just this idea of okay
uh have fun and reproduce and then on
like
on the on the on the non-progressive
side is still notions of wanting to own
other humans or
violence or kill and then on the
hyper-progressive side these strokes of
genius these kids that
and adults that may be two or three
standard deviations
up the bell curve are usually the ones
that like you said are able to
abstractly
reason these patterns in new creative
ways
in solving the greatest challenges that
exist
in creating the greatest art and i i
like that a lot
as long as as long as uh the people
within two standard deviations
don't drown out you know those people
yes and it's very easy to drown out
because
as people who are wired for survival
reproduction
that's the even our symbolic
manipulation is such
right yes it's easier to memorize the
characters in your telenovela
than it is or in your daytime soap than
it
is to memorize the families of hearts
and leptons for example
yes because they have no story right
yeah and that's so well said
so we need to tell the story we need to
tell an exciting
story that makes it even more fun
to know about the families of elementary
particles
and and beyond yeah and beyond well you
know
and then you know make them question it
later are there really family
supplementary particles
is there you know uh like like a donald
huffman
in the case against reality in this uh
book right you know
is this really what it is you know it's
what we're seeing
or is yeah yeah um and that's curiosity
right and that's curiosity i i like your
your point is very right that center of
the of the bell curve if
if the idea that i've been pushing
around a lot is that
the people that are in the sense two or
three standard deviations up the bell
curve
their general um purpose in a sense
also is to uh help
the people that are in the um in the
in the maybe one standard deviation to
zero
range up uh the bell curve to to help
them do a pull-up
in a sense to to go to the next level so
basically
you know like eric weinstein has the
idea of the portal like the
idea that you can create a portal
to help people in that center part of
the bell curve
go through the portal through these
stories and patterns that we can
disseminate to them to inspire them
to move up the bell curve and let's just
let's just jump into because we could
spend
we could spend so much of our time in
just that in just that section it's just
the beginning
um okay in general yes yes that's one
little thing
uh sharington in 1946-47 you know
uh he had he had a lecture uh uh
royal royal uh society where
he said that you know the movement of
society as regards
you know it's science technology culture
mathematics et cetera
in any one of those fields say physics
right um it's like an amoeba
uh you it throws off pseudopods or false
feet right uh
you know it it goes in one direction and
all you need is just a few of those
geniuses pulling and pulling and pulling
you know
until pretty soon the entire body of
society
is yes moved forward that's right so
and and and and that's that's what the
best that we can hope to happen
yes yes and what we don't like happening
is like
several of these pseudopodia being
thrown in different directions
you want a strong ball towards one so
you could pull
you know the the the social cultural
zeitgeist forward
yes yes yes you can pull the scientific
side guys
forward yes yes anyway yes beautifully
said i loved this first section it was
so powerful okay